es un potencial premio de consolación
aunque difícil de ganar 'rusia redobló
esfuerzos para acabar con los últimos
focos de resistencia en el donbass sus
fuerzas se enfrentaron a los soldados
ucranianos en las calles de las ciudades
estratégicas de cebreros nietes y
lysychansk
en general la situación es difícil ahora
aseveró don y es que es una mera
concentración de acciones de combate
entendemos que el ejército ruso está
lanzando todas sus fuerzas y reservas
las autoridades locales afirman que han
volado los puentes de los alrededores
para cortar las líneas de suministro de
ucrania pero aseguran que a pesar de
ello el ejército logró recapturar partes
de severodonezk pero rusia dice que las
fuerzas ucranianas se están retirando
también hubo ataques con misiles en la
ciudad de soledad en el donbass y un
aeródromo cerca de jarquín y el
ministerio de defensa ruso dijo que
habían derribado un avión de transporte
militar ucraniano cerca de deza mientras
los intensos combates tenían lugar una
fuerte reacción desde kiev tras el
pedido del presidente francés emmanuel
marco el viernes para no humillar a
rusia
a las terribles consecuencias de esta
guerra pueden detenerse en cualquier
momento el ejército ruso puede dejar de
quemar iglesias el ejército ruso puede
dejar de destruir ciudades el ejército
ruso puede dejar de matar niños si una
persona en moscú simplemente da esa
orden y el hecho de que todavía no haya
esa orden es obviamente una humillación
para todo el mundo
mccomb es uno de los pocos líderes
occidentales que ha intentado
repetidamente dialogar con el presidente
ruso a raíz de su creencia de que
francia puede desempeñar un papel
mediador en el conflicto